افادت مصادر تجاريه ان الحكومه تطالبت
المنتجين بانتاج اصناف من السلع الغذائيه
ذات جوده اقل وطرحها بسعر التكلفه وعدم
تحقيق اي ربح منها مع الابقاء على
منتجاتهم الاساسيه وتحميلها بالتكلفه
والارباح
بحثنا عن وزير التموين للتاكد فوجدناه
يفتتح معرض اهلا رمضان في محافظه
القليوبيه حيث التقيناه فاكد لنا صحه
المعلومه تم الاتفاق يا اما هيشتغلوا بسعر
التكلفه او يدوب سعر الجمله يعني بمعنى
اصح هامش ربح قليل وهنا هيتم ازاي ان
المصنع هيودي للمنفذ على طول ولن يمر
بحلقات تداول وبالتالي نقدر
نقلل التكلفه المعرض تنظمه الحكومه سنويا
قبل رمضان ليتم بيعه السلع الغذائيه فيه
بخصومات سعريه وعاده ما يقام قبل بدء شهر
الصوم باسبوع ولكن هذا العام اختارت
القاهره تنظيمه في جميع المحافظات على
مدار الاشهر الثلاثه القادمه كتخفيف عن
كاهل المواطنين
فاستطلعنا راي السيدات اللواتي اقبلنا على
شراء السلع المخفضه حول فكره قبول
المنتجات ذات جوده اقل مقابل تراجعي اسعار
اه مضطر عشان خاطر عيالي اسيبهم يعني
اه
غصب عني
ان احنا نجيب الحاجه الحلوه فبنضطر ان
احنا نعمل العيال اي حاجه علشان نكفي
يومنا على سبيل المثال طلبت الحكومه من
احدى شركات الزيوت التي تنتج 10 انواع
مختلفه ان تنتج ما يعرف بالاصناف الشعبيه
او زيوت الخليط وذلك باسعار في متناول
البسطاء لكن بعض التجار لم يتقبله هذه
الفكره ادي له منتج سيء واقول له معلش انا
قلت لك اثنين جنيه ثلاثه جنيه لا ما ينفعش
لا طبعا مش الكلام دوت الجوده الممتازه
الجوده كويسه هي دي اللي هتمشي في السوق
بالنسبه للكثيرين من من انشب غلاء الاسعار
اظافره في جيوبهم فقد لا يمنعون كثيرا
بالتنازل عن درجات من الجوده ولكن هل
يتقبل الجميع وهذا الامر فاذا كانت
الاجابه بلاء فما دعساهم يفعلون تامر نصره
العربيه محافظه القليوبيه